depuis longtemps j'éprouve un vif
intérêt pour tout ce qui est image
photographie montage vidéo aussi
quant à l'âge de 8 ans j'ai eu ma
première caméra je suis allé au lac des
minimes
pas très loin d'ici et j'étais mes
enthousiasmes et j'ai voulu tout filmé
dans les moindres détails je vous
épargne le reste c'était catastrophique
en tout cas ce cette vidéo m'a fait me
poser une question je me suis dit mais
pourquoi quand je bouge les yeux je n'ai
pas mal au coeur pourquoi quand je
déplace mes yeux aussi rapidement que
quand je déplace la caméra et bien
l'environnement reste stable et bien ça
a été le point de départ de mon
questionnement de chercheurs et j'ai
réalisé un certain nombre d'expériences
pour essayer de comprendre et je vais
vous présenter ce soir
certains de mes résultats alors avant de
vous présenter ses résultats je vais
vous donner quelques petites précisions
sur l'anatomie de la rétine humaine
il faut savoir que à l'arrière de l'oeil
sur la rétine
il ya une petite zone d'acuité visuelle
maximale petit parce qu'elle correspond
à mon ongle de pouce quand je tend le
bras
donc c'est vraiment petit et dans cette
zone quand les objets viennent se
projeter sur cette zone ils apparaissent
net alors que s'il se projette un peu
plus loin ils seront flou et distordu
juste un autre exemple pour bien vous
faire comprendre ce qui se passe si je
regarde un nuage
le nuage va me paraître net parce que
son image va se projeter sur la zone
d'accuser maximal 6 en dessous de ce
nuage il y à un oiseau je vais pouvoir
savoir que c'est un oiseau mais je ne
serai pas de galles c'est pourquoi parce
que son image se projette loin de la
zone d'acuité maximale c'est pour cela
que l'on fait des mouvements oculaires
qui s'appelle saccades oculaires
pourquoi saccades parce que ça va très
vite et seulement après ces saccades
oculaires je suis capable de vous dire
qu'il s'agit d'une mésange et non pas
d'un moineau ou d'un canari
par exemple ça veut dire que le cerveau
est capable de faire des prédictions en
moins de 50 millisecondes c'est
extrêmement rapide et des capable de
faire des prédictions sur ce qu'il va
voir après le mouvement oculaire
faisons un petit exercice ans semble pas
très compliqué vous êtes à priori en
train de me regarder
j'espère alors je vous demande continue
à me regarder c'est très important
continue à me regarder et vous allez
voir apparaître dans votre champ
périphériques mais vous me regardez donc
vous ne savez pas vous juste vous
imaginez que dans votre champ
périphérique vous avez un petit cercle
grille mais comme vous continuez à me
regarder continue à me regarder jusqu'à
ce que je vous donne le signal vous ne
savez pas ce qu'il y à l'intérieur de ce
cercle grille je vais vous donner le
signal et vous allez me regardait donc
deux mois et vous allez faire votre sac
à dos cullers vers le cercle gris
attention 1-2-3 saccades oculaires
hockey est là et uniquement après votre
sac à dos cullers vous êtes capable de
me dire que à l'intérieur de ce cercle
grille il y avait une image de
mappemonde et non pas une image de
quelque chose de rond qui serait un
ballon de football par exemple ou encore
l'image d'une tête avec un cerveau eh
bien c'est exactement ça qu'on demande
de faire à nos participants pendant
l'expérience
plus précisément on demande à nos
participants de venir dans une salle
dans laquelle il y à un ordinateur avec
une caméra ici à haute précision
spatiale et temporelle et pendant que
nos participants regarde les formes que
l'on projette sur l'écran donc par
exemple des formes rouges des formes
verte
eh bien on enregistre continuellement
les mouvements de leurs yeux ainsi on
demande à nos participants de faire des
mouvements oculaires de la gauche vers
la droite et de la droite vers la gauche
des saccades oculaires et gars autre
chose qu'il faut que je vous dise c'est
qu'en fait pendant qu'on déplace les
yeux on va tellement vite qu'on est
quasiment aveugle pendant qu'on déplace
les yeux mais vous essaierez ce soir
dans votre salle de bain enfin devant un
miroir et vous essaierez de faire c'est
saccades oculaires de la gauche vers la
droite et 2
la gauche et vous verrez pas à déplacer
vos yeux vous verrez uniquement un oeil
à gauche à droite et à gauche et à
droite
eh bien vous verrez à ce moment là que
on peut bénéficier de ce petit temps où
vous vous n'avez vous ne voyez rien pour
modifier les formes qu'on présente tout
cela à l'insu des participants on a donc
une première phase d'apprentissage qui
durait environ trois quarts d'heure et
pendant cette phase d'apprentissage ont
présenté par exemple des formes verte
ses formes vertes étaient des formes qui
était modifiée pendant que le
participant bouge les yeux si le
participant regard de la forme la forme
et triangulaire alors que si le
participant regarde ailleurs
la forme est plutôt ronde et bien sûr si
on demande aux participants es ce que
vous avez vu quelque chose
le participant ne s'en rend absolument
pas compte il ne nous dira pas oui vous
avez changé l'objet alors que je
déplaçais mes yeux on a également
présenté des objets rouges et ses objets
rouges étaient des objets quitté eux
identique que le participant regard de
l'objet ou qu'ils ne le regarde pas la
forme reste est tout à fait triangulaire
donc ses formes était présentée de
manière alternée aléatoire et répété
pendant trois quarts d'heure ce qui est
quand même pas beaucoup
suite à cette phase d'apprentissage il y
avait une phase de test ce test consiste
à dire aux participants maintenant il
faudrait nous décrire ce que vous voyez
avant de bouger les yeux on a présenté
des formes verte et ont demandé aux
participants d'ajuster avec les folles
et touches du clavier les formes de
manière à ce qu ils nous décrivent ce
qu'ils voyaient avant de bouger les yeux
on le faisait pour les formes verte et
on faisait aussi pour les formes rouges
alors pour la forme ouverte dans
l'exemple il s'agit ici d'un triangle de
participants nous décrit un triangle
alors que dans la forme rouge
il nous décrit quelque chose de plus
rond voici de manière très schématique
les résultats que nous avons obtenus
quand on présente deux formes identiques
mais de couleur différente donc les
formes sont identiques du point de vue
de leur cirque ne leur cure voiture donc
elles sont toutes les deux plutôt ronde
pour la forme verte le participant nous
dit où nous montre quelque chose de
beaucoup plus triangulaire alors que
pour la forme rouge
finalement la perception et plus
beaucoup plus proche de la réalité il
s'agit d'une forme qui est plutôt ronde
qu'est ce que cela nous suggère ça
suggère qu'on a réussi à modifier la
perception que nos sujets en des formes
présentées je vous répète ceci
complètement inconscient le sujet ne
sera absolument pas compte on a réussi
en trois quarts d'heure à modifier ses
perceptions a modifié la prédiction que
le cerveau est capable de faire des
prédictions en moins de 50 millisecondes
cela suggère aussi qu'on a été capable
de modifier quelque chose au niveau des
connexions nerveuses alors bien sûr de
manière transitoire et de manière
inconsciente quand les deux sujets sorte
de nos de nos laboratoires et ils n'ont
pas la perception complètement
complètement biaisé c'est vraiment
transitoire mais en tout cas ça nous
rappelle des phénomènes de plasticité
cérébrale qu'on observe de manière
beaucoup plus importante beaucoup plus
marquée par exemple chez des personnes
qui sont aveugles à l'arrière du cerveau
nous avons des zones ici dit visuel
pourquoi visuel parce qu'elles sont
activés par les objets visuels
quand on regarde l'environnement quand
on lit par exemple est bien chez des
personnes aveugles ou malvoyantes
il a été montré que ces zones visuel ici
peuvent être activés lorsque ces
personnes lisent le braille par
définition elles ne seront pas activé
par des stimulations visuelles mais par
des stimulations tactiles puisque les
personnes ne voient pas vous n'êtes pas
sans savoir non plus que au niveau de la
perception tactile
les personnes aveugles ou malvoyantes
ont une perception bien meilleure que la
nôtre
en tout cas ça montre cette fascinante
capacité du cerveau à se réorganiser en
fonction des événements de la vie en
fonction des interactions avec
l'environnement
c'est une capacité d'adaptation de
plasticité qui se fait au niveau
structurel et fonctionnel et bien nous
dans notre expérience nous avons de
manière beaucoup plus transitoire
beaucoup moins importante bien sûr
modifier ses capacités de prédiction et
d'anticipation alors ce que je peux dire
à la petite fille que j'étais quand
j'avais 8 ans qui se demandaient
pourquoi on avait pas mal au coeur quand
on bouge les yeux et bien finalement
c'est parce que notre cerveau a cette
capacité d'anticipation
cette capacité de prédiction qui est
adaptable qui s'adapte en fonction de
l'environnement
cette capacité qu'a le cerveau de
prévoir les ses propres les conséquences
de ses propres mouvements ça bien sûr la
caméra elle ne peut pas la voir
et d'ailleurs quand certaines personnes
sont sous l'emprise de l'alcool ou de
certaines substances psychoactives cette
capacité de prédiction est altéré cette
capacité d'anticipation est altérée et
l'environnement ne peut ne pas paraître
aussi stable en tout cas face à un
environnement en constant changement
face un environnement qui se
métamorphose
le cerveau a des capacités fascinante
d'adaptation il a des capacités de
trouver des points de repère et cette
capacité d'adaptation n'a pas fini de
nous étonner et de nous livrer ses
secrets
merci
[Applaudissements]